voilà un bien qui pourrait devenir
encore plus rare une maison avec jardin
après deux mois de confinement les
envies immobilières ont quelque peu
changé ses agents spécialisés dans les
maisons de familles ont reçu des
demandes et la troisième semaine de
confinement sur le deuxième mois de
confinement
ça a vraiment été beaucoup plus
intensifs pour vous donner des chiffres
concrets sur la même et même période
l'an dernier
donc le mois de mars et mois d'avril on
a connu une augmentation de ceux plus
110 % de la demande sur des maisons avec
jardin dans l'ouest parisien
le plus important pour les citadins ça
va être avoir un espace extérieur quels
qu'ils soient un petit peu de verdure
même une terrasse plus que le
confinement l'évolution des modes de
travail pourrait renforcer cette
recherche dans les yvelines après le 11
mai moins de 10% des salariés ont
réintégré leur entreprise ça c'est une
tendance assez générale à avoir une
pièce de plus pour les gens qui peuvent
se mettre un tel travail évidemment il
faut que l'activité qui est la leur leur
permettent de le faire mais il ya
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas de bureau
et qui souhaiteraient avoir un bureau
dédié pouvoir travailler de manière
efficace à distance un boom qui ne
pourrait être qu'un effet de mode pour
la fédération nationale de l'immobilier
entre 67 et 83 % des gens ne changerait
pas leur envie je vois mal quelqu'un qui
assemblera la défense un appartement à
neuilly sur seine puisque c'est juste à
côté peut y aller à pied ou alors à une
station de métro à les acheter une
maison à versailles ou un peu plus loin
avant jardin parce que le gars comme à y
revenir
et cette envie de jardin pourrait se
voir arrêter par un obstacle le budget
certains professionnels redoutent que
les banques réduisent les prêts aux
particuliers